heads up guys my name is the jono
welcome to a classic Hazel devlog so
today I wanted to talk about two major
new features in Hazel that we actually
shipped as part of our latest game for
those of you who don't know we made a
game called dichotomy I'll have a link
to a video up there if you want to check
out more details there'll also be a link
below to play it just a little game we
made in 72 hours for a game jam and I'm
sorry it's been such a long time between
devlogs honestly I've just been full
steam ahead working on Hazel or other
videos and I've had barely any time to
kind of document the journey it's a
little bit unfortunate because I would
have loved to have made more devlogs but
maybe we can do more of these chill ones
in that way I can find the time I think
a big problem for me is I just want to
like make them better produced and that
stops me from making anything at all and
I'm still kind of fighting that okay so
before we get into the two major pieces
of technology I just want to thank all
of the wonderful patreon supporters who
have made Hazel possible I actually
released a very long post on patreon
talking about the journey up until this
point in time and also what happens with
the money and how that actually funds
Hazel if you want to support Hazel's
development and get access to it then
patreon.com the Cherno is the place to
go okay so what are these two features
and why am I calling them such major
features so last time we actually
released something in Hazel was all the
way back in April it was a game called
Forest which we made also in 72 hours
for Londonderry a game Jam that was kind
of a major milestone in and of itself
and even though the game wasn't like
particularly good it was more of like a
tech test of what can we make it still
represented the first time that we were
able to actually ship a product with
hazel which up until then was something
we never did before well we actually
made a game like the day before that
game Jam started and quickly released it
just to make sure we could release
something and that game was called
fragile but we won't talk about that
however even though we were able to
physically ship a product it was far
from what I would consider like the
proper way to distribute games in
general I mean if we just take a look at
what Forest looked like when you
downloaded it so we had a launcher that
was pretty cool we could set our
settings we could hit play but if you
actually go into the directory this kind
of directory here is pretty much all of
like the raw assets and project files so
imagine that you've made a game in unity
but instead of like building it into
like a package and shipping it like as
an executable you kind of just ship the
unity project that's basically what we
did at that point in time if we look at
this a little bit more closely we can
see we have things like asimp here which
is like a 3D model importer which is not
generally something you would need in a
runtime of a game engine because you
should be using your own 3D model format
you shouldn't be using like fbx or gltf
because those are intermediate formats
but then if we go into like data we have
this assets folder and inside the assets
folder well guess what this is like all
of the raw assets like if we're going to
audio and Source we have a bunch of like
OG files here if we're going to mesh or
models we have all of these like gltf
files that we can just simply open and
here we have like this chest or whatever
all of these files are just here and
then inside scripts and binaries we also
have the main kind of C sharp dll this
isn't too much of a big deal this is how
Unity used to ship their games as well
before the whole il-2 CPP thing but in
general you can see how like I mean all
of the scenes for example like village.h
scene if we just open that up in Visual
Studio code you'll see that like I mean
it's all here you could edit like all of
this because it's all kind of like the
raw assets this is like physically the
scene file in yaml as hazelnut like the
Hazel editor would actually open it so
whilst it's obviously possible to ship a
game like that it's very far from ideal
there's two major reasons first of all
asset protection like you generally
don't want to give people the
opportunity to easily just steal your
assets and do whatever they want with
them I mean you could literally rip all
the assets and just like publish them on
a 3D model website I guess you could
argue that it makes modding really easy
like if I wanted to replace the a gun
model with something else it's as simple
as just replacing that gltf file and
you're kind of done so yeah whilst full
modding support out of the box might be
considered a positive feature in a lot
of regards overall it's probably not
that great to just give people access to
all of that the other major issue with
this though is performance so for
example let's take 3D meshes 3D meshes
have like some kind of model file and
they usually have like Associated
materials and textures specifically so
image files the two most common 3D model
formats that we kind of find today are
fbx and gltf there are certain other
ones but they're less popular both gltf
and fbx are known as intermediate 3D
mesh formats the reason they're called
intermediate formats is because
generally you work with those formats
when you're actually authoring assets
every single game engine like Unity
unreal frostbite whatever else they will
take that intermediate format and
they'll usually accept a whole range of
them and they will convert it into an
engine specific format because there is
basically no way that into immediate
format is going to be optimal for the
engine now of course you could do this
at runtime you could ship a game with an
fbx file or a gltf file and then you
could just read it and like process it
and transform the data I guess using
some kind of importer like asimp you
could roll your own whatever but the
fact is all of this processing that
you're doing doesn't really need to be
done because what's the point of opening
a file reading the parts that you need
and then changing them into some other
data structure or layout so for example
it might be extracting all of the vertex
positions all of the vertex normals
everything you need loading up buffers
and then sending that to your GPU as
like a Vertex buffer why would you do
that every single time you launch your
game clearly you're trying to get to the
same end result every time so why don't
you just do that processing ahead of
time and that way if you ship your game
with those assets already processed then
it is literally as simple as just read
the data from disk and into CPU memory
or read the vertex bar buffer data from
disk into GPU memory like that is that's
all you need to do because it's already
perfect it's already in the format you
want it to be so those are kind of the
two reasons why you might want your own
3D model format it's the same kind of
situation with textures for textures we
typically store like the master assets
as like a PNG or a JPEG maybe both of
those are compressed formats PNG
technically doesn't have to be
compressed but it usually is which means
that every time we read it we have to
decode it we have to go through and
process all those pixels decode the data
and then we might actually need to
compress it into a different format such
as like a GPU texture compression format
and then send it to the GPU that's so
much extra work for literally no reason
there might be some further processing
that needs to be done such as custom
filtering MIP maps for whatever reason a
great example of that might be for like
environment Maps you don't want to just
have your GPU linearly filter everything
you want to use a custom filtering
sampling algorithm that will give you
much nicer results I know I'm kind of
going down a rabbit hole here so I'll
probably we just digress at this point
and stop but you get the point hopefully
asset protection and performance slash
also I guess size of assets on disk you
might not use every portion of the model
so why would you want to ship everything
those are kind of the two downsides from
how we I guess shipped Assets in forest
and obviously I knew that this was
something that needed to change this was
just like a first step too let's just
ship something okay we can just ship it
in this format that will be easiest of
all because we don't need to spend time
creating our own formats and kind of
packaging all of this but now if we take
a look at dichotomy
so it looks very similar to just the raw
kind of folder here we have a launcher
we have obviously the graphic settings
and everything if we go into dichotomy
itself though and we take a look at it
we have this ld51 folder that's just
what it was called we've still got an
assets folder but if we look in the
assets folder this is what we've got
we've got this thing called a sound Bank
we've got an audio commands registry and
we've got an asset pack and you might
notice that the asset pack is actually
kind of large it's like 100 megabytes
inside the levels directory we have
these PNG files and each one of these
PNG files is a level inside dichotomy we
specifically didn't package these into
the asset pack because we wanted people
to be able to make their own levels and
the way the game actually works is it
reads this directory and it plays the
levels in like alphabetical order so in
that sense we kind of I guess shipped to
the game with modding support you could
say out of the box or at least your own
level kind of creation support out of
the box it also means you can delete
levels if they're giving you trouble and
then the game will simply skip them so
that's why the levels directory is here
but otherwise you might notice there's
no 3D models there's nothing it's
there's just an asset pack and that
asset pack contains like literally all
of the assets except for sounds all of
the audio assets are inside this sound
bank and there's also an audio commands
range this will probably likely also be
combined into the asset pack in the
future but because we have Jay working
on audio and he kind of started this
system before I started the whole asset
back system it was just a lot easier for
this game at least to just ship them as
two separate systems like this and this
asset packed file if we just open up
like a hex editor is just a bunch of
binary data you can see it has this
header age that AP Hazel asset pack and
manages binary data and it starts with
like an index and then it literally just
has the binary data for like everything
else now if you guys are interested I
might make an in-depth video talking
about like how this works on a technical
level and all of the details drop a
comment below if you'd like to see that
but otherwise all of the assets are just
inside this single file you can build
one of these from hazelnut Hazel's
editor by just going file build asset
pack and it will automatically build
this single file with all of the assets
that are actually referenced by your
scene so if you have a bunch of assets
that you don't even use it's going to
skip all of those all of the assets that
are actually used inside your scenes and
inside your game they will be packaged
over here and when you actually launch
the games if we just launch dichotomy
you'll see over here in the bottom we
like for the first I think eight seconds
or so it shows this right and then after
a while it goes away if we open it again
here it is and it says the version of
the binary as well as the version of the
asset pack and they're separate because
obviously like the asset pack is
separate to that executable binary of
the actual like game application and you
can kind of update them separately
completely and you might want to see
what version of issue on if we just
launch this again you might notice that
this number is pretty big it's actually
the date and time so here we have like
the year the month the day and then the
time in like 24 hour times like 407 pm
and the reason it's like this is because
this is very very useful when you're
actually shipping this because you know
exactly when you built this so therefore
what version am I shipping like what is
this asset pack when was it built so I
really like having this instead of just
like some kind of arbitrary incrementing
version like we do currently for the
actual executable binary builds now the
other thing you might notice is that
other kind of binary the other dll we
had here asimp this is gone we don't
need it anymore because everything you
see here all of the 3D models like these
things which are actually skeletal
animations that's entirely using Hazel's
own model format that has nothing to do
with asimp and it's already in that
perfect like data layout where we can
just read it from disk and we have
everything we need so for example like
the entire node hierarchy all of the
bones all of the stuff we need to know
for that that sub mesh transforms all of
that can just be copied directly into
like a CPU size struct and then all the
vertex buffers and index buffers are
also just stored as is on disk so we can
just kind of stream them in basically
directly 2 GPU memory and that's it and
the performance gains of that are just
huge in fact I might make a video
talking about the performance of this
specifically because I think it's just
such a useful thing to do and it seems
obvious but I don't know maybe some of
you haven't even thought of making your
own three model format so yeah highly
recommend now the second major feature
that we shipped with
what's that what's the time it's oh wow
I've been recording for a long time huh
guess you guys will just have to wait
till the next devlog soz maybe uh maybe
download Hazel while you're waiting and
then you'll see